[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to the
chapter 101 attack on Titan review this
was such a crazy chapter I'm not even
gonna talk about how crazy was the
previous chapters were all good I
enjoyed them quite a bit but this one
really stands out as the best and most
interesting chapter in a long time for
me personally we finally saw the
Warhammer Titan revealed the Warhammer
Titan in action
we saw the return of a beloved character
from the island and so much more please
excuse the delay in uploading this
chapter as you may know my chapter 100
review was taken down by a false
copyright claim and even though I
appealed it right away I still haven't
heard back from YouTube almost a month
later I heard from a few people that
they sometimes target the earliest
videos that go up and since I can't risk
another unfair strike on the channel I
decided to hold off on this hopefully
this one will not be taken down again
like I said it definitely meets fair use
but we'll have to wait and see I know
that if you want the most views possible
the best thing to do is to upload the
video as soon as possible but at the end
of the day I heard from so many of you
guys who really enjoyed these reviews
and you will watch it no matter when it
comes out and that's what really matters
to me I make these reviews for you guys
who really enjoy it not just to get the
most views so thank you again for all
the support you've shown during this
past month with the previous video being
taken down and everything it really
means a lot to me guys as always if you
enjoyed these reviews be sure to leave a
like if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you could be
notified every time I upload a new
review this chapter starts off with
Eden's attack Titan devouring Willie's
body
I'm sure Aaron was hoping to obtain the
Warhammer Titan power by doing this and
of course this proves that Willie and
Aaron were definitely not working
together because it turns out that
Willie was not the Warhammer type
after all and the theory I proposed in
my recent where is the Warhammer Titan
video was true which is pretty cool I
have to say as Eden wrecks havoc around
the festival area killing a whole bunch
of civilians including Sofia and we also
see that Udo is terribly injured if not
killed as well it is revealed that the
true Warhammer Titan was another member
of the Tiber family
Willie's sister now this makes perfect
sense to me
the timers would want to keep the
Warhammer Titan power as safe as
possible so lying that Willy has it when
someone else does is actually a good way
to protect themselves in case somebody
tries to go after them I think this is a
good strategy as the sister begins to
transform Eren flies at her right away
and start doing damage he's not waiting
for the transformation he's jumping in
right away like a true soldier using
every possible second to his advantage
as Willy had already predicted most of
the male leadership is wiped out by
Aaron's attack and general McGrath
assumes command he prepares anti-titan
cannons in order to attack Aaron's
attack Titan and he also makes a comment
about going to the island implying that
the Marlin military plans to use the
fact that the founding Titan isn't male
2 now attack parodies however why do
they need to go to the island if the
founding Titan is right here we learned
that my gas no longer considers
capturing the founding Titan a priority
he believes that the era of Titan
dominance is over and he orders Eren to
be killed I wonder does McGrath want to
go to the island in order to kill all
the audience there is it connected to
the female Titan and rescuing any in
some way or is it just about the
resources that the island has I'm not
sure at this point but let me know what
you guys think
why does my gas want to go to paradise
even though the founding Titan is right
there in front of him we soon learned
that the Warhammer Titans special
ability seems to be to create weapons
including a giant spike that shoots up
from the earth to impale Eren and of
a hammer it's as if this Titan uses the
ability that Titans have to harden their
bodies in a way that allows it to create
powerful weapons that are not connected
to its body
I wonder if back in the days of the LDN
Empire the Warhammer time actually
created powerful weapons for the other
shifters to use in battle
we then see Porco and peek inside the
underground dungeon and the theories
that some of you mentioned in the
comments on the previous chapter reviews
were true peek was suspicious of the
soldier that led them to the trap so she
instructed the one soldier she briefly
hugged to follow them and see where the
mystery soldier is taking them the
soldier peak spoke with rescue speak and
pour core and they make their way back
up to the street but as they do this
they see the survey Corps from parodies
storming lab area with their 3d
maneuvering gear which is just an epic
scene and a massive development back at
the festival Plaza the Warhammer Titan
has fully transformed and with the help
of the male military cannons the
Warhammer Titan manages to take out the
attack Titans head with its hammer and
then we see Eden emerging from the
attack Titan in all of his long-haired
glory the Warhammer Titan speaks to Eren
asking if he has any final words and of
course we know that the Tiber family is
a noble family so that could be related
to why the Warhammer Titan can speak so
clearly in Titan form we know of course
that Zeke who also has royal blood can
do the same but then just as we think
that Eden might be about to get hammered
he says do it now Mikasa and the survey
Corps shows up including our girl Mikasa
who launches a bunch of thunder spears
into the Warhammer Titans neck while the
other survey Corps members go at it with
the Marlins soldiers
Mikasa says Aaron please come home and
this is how this epic chapter ends Mika
says hair by the way is even shorter
than before even though I was personally
hoping for longer but she is still as
amazing as
there are so many questions right now
clearly Aaron was communicating with
Mikasa and the survey Corps at some
point because they showed up just in
time but you'll notice that Nika sucess
- Aaron please come home so that implies
that Eden has been male on his own at
least for a while and Mikasa wants him
to come home so that means that this
plan may have been Aaron's idea and
Mikasa wasn't fully on board out of the
survey Corps we appear to have also seen
Jean or Jean very briefly but still no
Levi Sasha
Connie or the others and of course know
Armin who is the Colossus Titan I wonder
if Armin is here waiting to make his
move or if maybe he is still on paradise
waiting for the Marlin army to make
their move so that he can stomp them out
we can't forget that Porco and peak will
now transform into their Titan forms and
the Warhammer Titan is probably still
alive somehow since I doubt it would go
down so easily
not to mention Reiner who is still there
in the underground chamber and of course
Zeke should be there somewhere but I am
definitely now willing to bet that Zeke
is working with Aaron in some capacity
Zeke knew what was about to happen he
made sure that Porco and peek were out
of the way he made sure that Reiner went
into the underground room to talk to
Aaron and I'm willing to bet that Zeke
helped Aaron organize this plan in the
first place and maybe that's why Mikasa
wants Eren to come home because she
doesn't trust Zeke and she knows that
Aaron is working with it so the
situation as we have it now is pretty
intense to say the least we have
multiple Titan shifters loyal to Marlay
that could spell disaster for Eren
Mikasa and the others but we also have
the survey Corps with their 3d
maneuvering gear that the Marlin
soldiers are not used to fighting
against so that is a huge advantage and
an element of surprise on top of that we
have our men and his Colossus Titan who
might be somewhere here
well so many pieces are in place so many
things could happen next
just brilliant writing and a fascinating
development of events one thing that
really took me back was to see Aaron
murdering all of these civilians in much
the same way as Reiner Annie and
Berthold killed all those innocent
people on parodies Gabby's reaction was
a lot like the reaction of Armin Mikasa
and Aaron back then which brings the
whole story full circle and this really
shows us that in war even good people
are sometimes forced to do terrible
things Aaron sees what he's doing as
fighting back against the people who
murdered so many of the people that he
cared about against people who attacked
him first and Aaron is trying to make
sure that the LD ins on the island are
not exterminated so he is doing whatever
it takes to win and of course this is in
many ways like what Reiner and the
others were doing they thought that they
were saving the world by killing the
evil aliens the Devils on parodies this
is a really interesting juxtaposition
here and again a profound message about
the true nature of war clear-cut good
guys and bad guys exist in movies but in
the real world it is much harder to tell
who is truly good and who is bad in war
each side thinks that they are doing the
right thing and fighting for the right
cause and there are always casualties on
all sides one thing to keep in mind
though is that if Armin is somewhere in
Marlay then the reason that he hasn't
transformed yet is because Aaron and the
others are trying to avoid civilian
casualties if they can just think about
it if they had chosen to attack with the
Colossus Titan the civilian casualties
would have been much much greater so
well of course it is sad to see any
innocent people die if the Colossus
Titan is indeed in Marlay and they are
keeping him hidden it is because Eren
Mikasa and the others are still doing
their best to avoid civilian casualties
if they can help it overall it is just
very hard to predict what happens next
but give me your thoughts down in the
car
do you like the design of the Warhammer
Titan and do you think that it has an
impressive power personally I was
thinking that we might see something
related to lightning since the Warhammer
is associated with Thor the God of
Thunder in Norse mythology and we know
that attack on Titan is heavily
influenced by Norse mythology but to be
perfectly honest I still think this
Warhammer Titan design is pretty cool
and the power seems very impressive also
another huge question for me
what is Zeke up to where was he in this
chapter as the chapters have been going
on I keep getting more and more curious
about Zeke and his true intentions also
when will Levi make his move I can't
wait to see him again and of course I
can't wait to see Arman's Colossus Titan
form finally what about Reiner how do
you think he feels now that the tables
have been turned and his hometown has
been attacked by Eden and the survey
corps what will he do next will he fight
will he try to stop the fighting because
he knows there are good people on both
sides or will he just wallow in
depression give me your thoughts down
below I love to hear from you thank you
again for all the support you've shown
regarding the whole last review being
taken down it's a hard thing to deal
with but again thank you so much if you
enjoy these reviews and want to see more
be sure to leave a like to let me know
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you can be notified every time I
upload a new review as always thank you
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]